jurassic world dominion is the
culmination of the franchise this is
what everything has been leading to
jurassic park is back and it's unlike
anything we've ever seen before
they've got a blend of old technologies
new stories and a whole lot of dinosaurs
we're taking a sneak peek behind the
scenes to see all the details that made
this movie so epic
number one they weren't kidding around
there have never been more dinosaurs
than there are in dominion in a movie
for real they went ahead and broke their
own record like maximum amount of
dinosaurs in this movie that we're
making part of the reason for this was
because there are actually just a ton of
dinosaurs that they were able to include
one of the great things about having
dinosaurs in the movie is that you're
never going to run out of them
there's always a new species with the
opportunity to bring loads of new
dinosaurs to the screen they didn't hold
back in this movie we have some
incredible new dinosaurs to look at and
to watch behave
all these prehistoric creatures are
thanks to one very special designer
it is a it is a specialized craft
to see what john nolan was capable of
number two
if it ain't broke don't fix it this is
sort of back to
basics in the best possible sense when
the og cast was asked to return some of
them had mixed feelings about the new
technology that could be introduced when
we were asked to do this we assumed with
the level of advancements in cgi
it would be amazing and digitally
enhanced but they were wrong while the
idea of cg was super cool there was a
concern the movie wouldn't have the same
dino world magic but their director
colin knew the only way to do it was the
same way they'd started and you walk on
set are either completely disgusted or
in awe or both there was no shortage of
animatronics for these actors to work
with to be able to work with the 3d
thing makes life so much more vivid
these real breathing dinosaurs made the
set feel like another world making it
extremely easy for the actors to feel
transported they make all of it come
alive number three
sometimes you gotta do like the gators
do even if that means getting soaking
wet wading through water braced dallas
howard was just committing to her craft
plus who wouldn't want to take a little
dip at work
number four
who wants to bet there were snowball
fights
you see dinosaurs in snow
for real and you get to see chris pratt
having a wild time in the snow as well
when you've got snow covered sets to
work with you've got to milk it for all
it's worth the jurassic team knew what
they were doing and no doubt chris pratt
had a blast filming at least we hope so
number five
these are the new dinos on the block we
have amazing dinosaur sequences there
are a number of new dinosaurs that join
jurassic world but one of the most
exciting the feathered dino they've
created a dinosaur now that is going to
honor dinosaurs that are feathered and
while it's super cool it's equally
terrifying this thing is for reeky
really really scary and can we just take
a moment of appreciation for these teeny
tiny cute dinosaurs sure they're
freakishly realistic but you gotta give
it to them they are cute
number six it was a jurassic family
reunion in jurassic world dominion you
will see the original cast members back
for this movie to work the original cast
had to be on board but there were some
concerns off the bat first thing they
asked was is it a cameo no no it's a
real role this was a totally new story
using the best of both worlds first
trilogy had characters who we loved and
then the sequels were about owen and
claire and now in the case of dominion
we wanted to integrate them once
everyone knew how much of a coming
together this would really be the cast
was over the moon and ready to sign on
the dotted line 19 years ago laura dern
and sam neil did what they thought was
their last performance in the jurassic
world but it's never too late to go home
number seven
literally
it wasn't just dinos on these sets
that said the horse actors never had to
face any real dinos themselves we doubt
that would have been helpful for their
performances
number eight
sorry how fast can dinosaurs run when
racing against a dinosaur you'd best be
using a car the movie had its fair share
of car races through the streets
complete with moving cameras and even
drones oh yeah and chris pratt on a
motorbike
number nine
need to crash something the dominion
team got you covered no cgi here
creating the crashed plane amidst the
chaotic ice and snow as for the car
crash well what would you expect they
weren't holding back on dinosaurs they
had to go out with everything else these
busted up vehicles were just small
peanuts for this crew
number 10
it wouldn't be jurassic park without
some wild stunts including falling and
flying through the air on wires while
the actors did a number of their own
when it came to the more risky moments
they left it to the stunt doubles none
of them would have wanted to be left
hanging after all
number 11
no one could resist sneaking a peek like
you haven't seen jurassic like this ever
before the actors on the jurassic world
dominion set were regularly found behind
the camera chatting with their director
in part because of just how brilliant an
eye colin trevaro has colin is
fascinating because he knows so much
about the camera as well as like just
talking with actors the director was a
mentor for many performers gotten to
learn uh quite a bit about the camera
talking with him and he's earned every
bit of praise he gets
this guy has worked some real-life magic
after setting up all these shots and
like the animatronic stuff and dealing
with all that stuff is kind of like
wizard-like number 12.
dinos car crashes what other action did
they need
how could they get away with doing the
movie without some fire on set
unfortunately for the locusts fire on
set was no good for their future
number 13
we're talking literal fans here that's
right when you're dealing with dinosaurs
you've got to break out the heavy duty
equipment
including all the huge fans you can find
while editing played some part in
bringing the final image together the
actors were dealing with some seriously
ferocious wins on set to amp up the more
dramatic moments
number 14.
who didn't want to visit jurassic park
as a kid for actor mamadou athey the
experience of being on set amongst all
this magic he grew up with watching was
once in a lifetime very very surreal
getting to bring his own character to a
world he was already so familiar to made
it that much easier for him to perform
it definitely helped that this was one
of the most special experiences he'd
ever had in his life i grew up
with this and these characters and it
was just kind of cool number 15
the dinosaur budget alone was massive
when you're doing a movie that brings so
much hype you've got to do it right from
the beginning we really wanted to make
something that was new enough and fresh
enough that it could give people a
reason to come back to the theater it
wasn't going to be cheap to do this
though no wonder they spent
165 million dollars u.s on the film we
had
truly have spared no expense yeah no
kidding the hope was it would all pay
off if they could connect with new fans
also give kids a reason to hopefully go
back and watch the original films hey
they're classic movies for a reason okay
who else wishes they could be on those
sets hanging out with all those dinos we
can't believe all those creatures were
real do you think they made the right
call or would you have liked to see some
cg dinos let us know in the comments
you